The antarctic ice sheet is DEFINITELY MELTING!
Here's a crazy idea: let's NOT wait until
millions of people are homeless before we
do something about it. Eh? Eh?
Hello folks, Laci Green here for DNews. When
it comes to the rising sea level, one of the
key players is our Southern buddy Antarctica.
Antarctica is a something of a neglected continent
because basically nobody lives there-- but
it is about twice the size of Australia and
contains 90% of the earth's ice. The entire
continent is basically a 1 mile thick slab
of ice. If the whole thing were to melt, the
sea level across the planet would rise 200
feet. And humanity would be TOTALLY screwed.
Fortunately, we're only SLIGHTLY screwed.
Multiple studies published in the journal
Science predict that we're looking at closer
to a TEN foot increase in sea level across
the planet by the year 2200. So hey! It's
not 200 hundred feet...but 10 is still a lot,
even across the projected 200 year period.
By the time your great-great-grandbabies are
walking the earth, around 29,000 square miles
of US land will be under water -- land that
is currently inhabited by over 12 million
people. Researchers at Climate Central say
that New York City, New Orleans, Miami and
DC will be the areas that are most heavily
flooded. Various coastal cities in Texas,
New Jersey, New England, Virginia, California
will also be severely affected. In Florida,
the highest risk area, ⅓ of all its housing
will go under, and because of what are essentially
holes in Florida's bedrock, levees and seawalls
will be useless. On a global scale, thirteen
of the world's largest cities and about 25%
of humanity rests in coastal areas that will
be affected. Some inhabited islands, like
the Maldives, are projected to go underwater
completely. Of course, this kind of rise also
poses a great threat for severe flooding during
storms like Hurricane Katrina and Hurricane
Sandy. Plus tsunami zones from earthquakes
will extend much further back into the land.
BUT! Before you freak, keep in mind that this
is something that will happen SLOWLY, over
time. It's not an overnight thing. The melt
predicted is also not reversible, it's gonna
happen, so cities will need to figure out
how they will handle the physical and economic
impacts -- a process that begins by scientists
and policymakers working together and asking
the right questions to get started. The American
Geophysical Union is already asking: alright
guys, what's our approach here? Should we
build up our seawalls? Should we start to
zone future buildings and real estate further
up on the land? How will this affect our economy?
To prevent even more sea level rising, we
should also be seriously thinking about what
role humans play in preventing more ice melting.
The common response to this kind of news is
usually fear (OH MY GOD!) followed by apathy
(I DON'T CARE!). I'd argue that the proper
response isn't fear or apathy at all -- it's
action. Action in the form of prevention and
adaptation. Time to roll up those sleeves
and get to work. What do you think? Tell me
about it down below and I'll see you next
time with more science updates.